something's changed in the town of
bhavinkova
the russian invasion
was a theoretical threat
but it's starting to feel very real
it's getting closer isn't it
yep says this reservist
these men or volunteers have been turned
into frontline troops and we found them
digging trenches and preparing
barricades on the outskirts of town
the russians sent reminders of their
progress their shells pounding a nearby
field while the local commander pondered
past and present
the russian military is on the move
attempting to encircle ukrainian troops
in the east
and they have plenty of tools at their
disposal
[Music]
it's a drone
we took cover as a drone circled
overhead
the weather is perfect for them
it might be the most frightening thing
for the people on the ground right now
the all clear given the troops got back
to work
and there's no problem with morale in
bavinkava but there may be an issue with
the equipment this gun dates from the
1940s
on a nearby hilltop we were greeted by
the sight and the sound of ukrainian
tanks heading towards the front line
[Music]
[Applause]
while technicians were busy preparing
others for battle
however there was one crew focused on a
new piece of property
something picked up a couple of
kilometers away
this is a russian t-72 tank it's been
actually captured from the russians it
was damaged they're making repairs
and loading it up with ammunition and
they'll be ready to go this afternoon
they say
how important is it to be able to
to get these things up and running
[Music]
in the center of town members of a
volunteer battalion made their final
preparations before heading to the front
some listen to music
[Music]
i will not die roared the singer
and they all wrapped blue tape around
their arms it's the way ukrainians
identify themselves
if i say
people
are not scared or something like this
it's bull everybody a bit scared
that's normal that's woah
nobody assume
he'll return to home
yeah nobody should he will see them his
family uh his
girlfriend and others
so everybody a bit scary
in bavinkava there is courage and there
is fear for the ukrainians are outmanned
and outgunned by their adversary
but there is something here worth
fighting for and they are prepared to
pay the price
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine